so I just spoke about how Mitch
McConnell told reporters he doesn't like
Republicans chances at winning the
senate in 2022 because Senate races have
a lot to do with candidate quality sort
of alluding to the fact that he doesn't
think a lot of these Republican
candidates are high quality candidates
and are a little bit too out there to
win these elections let's take a look
again at the clip as a reminder I think
the the
there's a probably a greater likelihood
the house flips in the center
Senate races are just different they're
Statewide
candidate quality has a lot to do with
the outcome well another person in
addition to Sean Hannity who is furious
with McConnell's comments here is Donald
Trump who of course has invested
interest in the outcome of the 2022
midterms because he needs to see this
big red wave with as many of his
candidates winning as possible in order
to feed into the narrative that you need
Trump as the figurehead of the
Republican party if you want to win back
the White House in 2024 so Trump made a
statement on Truth social bashing
McConnell which isn't all that new
really Trump has been treating McConnell
as a pinata for years now but he even
went so far as to bring McConnell's wife
into the mix and call her crazy Trump
said quote why do Republican Senators
allow a broken down hack politician
Mitch McConnell to openly disparage
hard-working Republican candidates for
the United States Senate this is such an
affront to honor and to leadership he
should spend more time and money helping
them get elected and less time helping
his crazy wife and family get rich on
China so I believe that what Donald
Trump is doing here is setting the
groundwork in place to have something
else to blame the 2022 midterm defeats
on in the event that his candidates lose
their respective races and he really
just has so many built-in excuses at
this point like if an anti-trumper or a
half-trump supporting candidate loses
their race well he can just jump in and
say that's because they were against me
they were not a true pro-trump candidate
and that's exactly why they lost if you
have a pro-trump but doesn't want to
talk about him too much type of
candidate someone like a Dr Oz for
example and they lose well Trump could
jump in and say well that's because they
weren't embracing me enough right I
tried to do a rally in their home state
and they turned me down if they had
embraced me more clearly they would have
won and then in this sort of situation
if you have someone who is a full-on pro
Trump supporting candidate where those
excuses that I laid out previously
wouldn't work now he can just blame
Mitch McConnell he can say that well
Mitch didn't believe in the candidate
and the nrsc the national Republican
senatorial committee they didn't spend
enough on their race and that's exactly
why they lost it has nothing to do with
me and then the all of the above excuse
he can always use is that there was
voter fraud so you always had that one
in your back pocket too that's a
favorite among Republicans these days
and then the second interesting thing
about this post by Trump is the choice
to go after Mitch McConnell's wife who
is Elaine chow chow worked in Trump's
cabinet she was his Transportation
secretary and she actually resigned in
protest after the January 6th Capital
riots so apparently that's what got her
on Trump's bad side and that's why Trump
sees her as crazy now and you gotta
wonder how Mitch McConnell is going to
respond to this if he's going to say
anything about it at all because we know
that McConnell has been very wishy-washy
about Trump in recent years he clearly
doesn't like Trump he doesn't like the
power that Trump has over him and the
rest of the Republican party but at the
same time he knows that his Kentucky
constituents like Trump and he knows
that if he wants to remain in charge of
the Republicans in the Senate he still
has to at least give lip service to
Trump being in charge of everything and
um because otherwise they'll decide to
oust him as the minority leader and so
he's in this horrible position of having
to maybe defend the person who just
insulted his wife it's exactly what Ted
Cruz had to face a couple of years ago
where Trump called Cruz's wife ugly and
despite how humiliating it was Cruz
eventually had to come around and defend
Trump Back Him support him phone bank
for him and just become a normal
trumpist so we'll see if Mitch McConnell
decides to go the Ted Cruz route or if
he'll have a little bit more courage and
decide to stand up for his wife what an
incredible situation that Mitch
McConnell finds himself in and clearly
Trump hasn't learned his lesson that you
shouldn't go after people's spouses
because why would he Ted Cruz let him
get away with it so maybe Mitch
McConnell will too and will this lead to
McConnell being more aggressive against
Trump I'm not going to hold my breath
let's talk about vpn's virtual private
networks even if you're using incognito
mode on your browser if you're not using
a VPN everything you do online can be
recorded by your internet provider and
that is permanent because they're
selling it search engines social media
companies are also tracking your every
move you only need one thing to protect
yourself from all of it private internet
access one of our sponsors it's a VPN
it's simple you take a moment and you
download it you turn it on and you're
protected and you stay protected and
that's it vpns can also keep your
connection secure from hackers important
every time you check your bank account
or 401k or pension otherwise it can all
be out in the open private internet
access never records or stores user data
they've even proven this policy multiple
times in court their software is open
source to show that there's no data
being logged this trans transparency is
why private internet access is the VPN I
use and my audience gets 82 percent off
so you can stay protected for Just Two
Dollars and 11 cents a month plus you'll
get three months free go to
privateinternetaccess.com Pacman the
link is down below